ليله حناء رجوى ال سيف نجوم عرب يشاركون
الاردنيين فرحهم بالامير الحسين اطلالات
وتصريحات اثاره الجدل للفنانين المصريين
والوضع الصحي لسيلين ديون يتفاقم بشكل
محبط اليكم الابرز الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
تصدر حفل الحناء الذي اقامته الملكه رانيا
لعروس ولي عهد الاردن السعوديه رجوى ال
سيف ابرز الاحداث التي حققت تفاعلا على
منصات التواصل في العالم العربي الاسبوع
الماضي وافتتح هذا الحفل الاحتفالات
الملكيه بزفاف ولي العهد الامير الحسين بن
عبد الله الثاني المقرر اقامته الخميس في
الاول من حزيران يونيو المقبل
[تصفيق]
يا سعوديه وطيه اردنيه ولا فتاه الملكه
رانيا الانظار باطلالتها الانيقه التي
حملت توقيع مصمم الازياء اللبناني سعيد
قبيسي وكذلك عبر متابعون على منصات
التواصل عن اعجابهم بفستان حناء العروس
رجوى ال سيف من تصميم السعوديه هنيده خاصه
العباره التي نسجت على الفستان بخيوط
ذهبيه اراك فتحلو الحياه الاردن بالحب ولا
اقوى بالفرح النجوم وعم تضوى فرح الحسين
ورجوه
وفرحان واهدى المطرب اللبناني راغب علامه
ولي عهد الاردن وعروسه السعوديه اغنيه
بمناسبه مراسم زفافهما من المتوقع ان
يؤديها في حفل جماهيري مرتقب بهذه
المناسبه يشارك فيه ايضا تامر حسني واحمد
سعد بن مصر والفنانتان الاردنيتان ديانا
كرزون وزين عوض كما يحيي المطرب الاماراتي
حسين الجسمي حفلا جماهريا اخر بمناسبه
زفاف ولي عهد الاردن مهدى من دوله
الامارات على المدرج الروماني في عمان
ومن عمان الى جده التي شهدت الاسبوع
الماضي حفلا جماهيريا للفنانه المصريه
شيرين عبد الوهاب بعد تكثيف نشاطها الفني
مؤخرا كما احيا الفنان المصري محمد فؤاد
في جده ايضا حفلا حقق الكثير من التفاعل
على منصات التواصل والجدل في مصر بعد
تصريحات عبر فيها عن سعادته بالغناء لمن
وصفهم اعظم ناس على وجه الارض الامر الذي
اعتبره متابعون المصريون نوعا من التجاهل
تاريخه الفني الذي صنعه في بلاده
[موسيقى]
وشاركه الحفل المطرب المصري احمد سعد الذي
نال نصيبا واثرا من التفاعل والجدل ايضا
بسبب اطلالته
سعد تدوينه على انستجرام قال فيها
اختيارات مدمره حياتي وراى فيها البعض
تعليقا او اشاره ساخره منه لردود الافعال
على اطالته وقد اثارت اطاله شقيقه الفنان
عمرو سعد جدلا مشابها وكان من مفاجات حفل
جده مشاركه عمرو لشقيقه احمد الغناء
وامتد جدل الاطلالات الاخيره لبعض
الفنانين المصريين للفنان محمد رمضان الذي
ظهر بقميص اعتبر خارجا عن المالوف في عيد
ميلاده الذي احتفل فيه مع رجل الاعمال
المصري نجيب ساويرس والمخرج محمد سامي
والفنانه المصريه هاله صدقي واخرين كما
نشر رمضان فيديو من الاحتفال بعيد ميلاده
بكيكه تزينت بالدولارات وذلك بعد وقت قصير
من الجدل الذي اثارته صوره له الى جانب
روزم منها
عالميا اعلنت سيلين ديون عن الغاء مواعيد
جولتها الغنائيه العالميه حتى
2024 ومن المحتمل الا تقوم بجوله مره اخرى
بحسب ما قال مصدر مقرب من ديون بشبكه سي
ان ان وجاء الاعلام في بيان نشرته المغنيه
الكنديه على منصات التواصل قالت فيه اسفه
للغايه لاحباط امالكم جميعا انا اعمل بجد
لاعاده بناء قوتي مره اخرى واضافت لن
استسلم ولا اطيق الانتظار لرؤيتكم وكان
سيرين ديون قد اجلت العديد من العروض في
ديسمبر الماضي بعد ان اعلنت اصابتها
بمتلازمه الشخص المتيبس وهي حاله على حد
قولها لا تسمح لها بالغناء بالطريقه التي
اعتادت عليها
سيلين ديون كانت قد عبرت عن حزنها الشديد
وكذلك نجوم عالميون اخرون لرحيل ايقونه
الروك الامريكيه تينا تورنر عن عمر 83
عاما في سويسرا وفي دمشق اعلن صباح
الاثنين عن رحيل الفنان السوري اسامه
الروماني عن عمر واحد وثمانين عاما ومن
اشهر ادواره المسرحيه مشاركته في مسرحيتي
ضيعه تشرين وغربه الى جانب احد رفاق دربه
الفنان السوري دريد لحام
[موسيقى]